reading some podcasts value bad
[ __ ] it's Monday the eleven to
make a beautiful mother [ __ ] dinner
be alive kick this [ __ ] mealy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's Monday the 11th of [ __ ] May if
you home your home if you out you out
just keep your mask on and don't get
don't [ __ ] breathe on me [ __ ]
sir
it's another great week the Church of
what's happened now is here the [ __ ] to
hit you again again this week no [ __ ]
guests no masks we're going back to the
[ __ ] his room I got a great zoom for
you I got one of my buddies I've been
friends with 279 if anybody wants to
ever investigate me to write a book this
guy I'll tell you everything you need to
know cuz he's seen him across the way he
was there when in 85 for me when I got
clean he saw me get taken away into a
[ __ ] back room when I got sentenced
he saw me get out he saw me get on stage
and he's still one of my best brothers
today you have no idea how lucky I am to
have in my life he's only on the podcast
Monday and [ __ ] Wednesday
that's how big enough time we got with
him but uh besides that it's [ __ ] up
Monday I don't know what's going on in
your life I don't know if you got the
stimulus check I don't know if you got
your employment but you know what you're
alive so stop the [ __ ] frown and get
to it [ __ ] let's talk about
upsets Tony Ferguson versus just
engaging great fight
there hasn't been nothing going on so I
smelled a rat somewhere along the line
but I didn't see that coming at all I
like to congratulate just engaging I
like to congratulate Ferguson for the
[ __ ] streak that he put together I
was like a 12 or 13 fight streak but you
know I always say man it's like calmly
things change you can't settle too much
in your success you gotta take it it's
for today and tomorrow's another day
that's a problem we have we think that
this [ __ ] you know you it's like I was
watching this movie that they uh what uh
it's what Ben Stiller and the guy who
loaded on heroin Oh unlock and pop Along
Came paulien
he's a guy that's did something ten
years ago but he's still walking around
what's a guy see
he's walking around it's like me if I
all I did was talk about spider-man -
you know it's like watching the fighter
and the guys brother fought Sugar Ray
Hagler Sugar Ray Leonard and he in one
of the Rings rounds he slipped and he
said he'd knocked him down so his claim
to fame was you know I knocked down
Sugar Ray Leonard when I fought him in
1973 that's great but the 2020 what have
you done lately you [ __ ] and this is
why I believe that we do [ __ ] on a
[ __ ] daily you know and the UFC's
something like they comedy it's just
moving fast now comedy stuck we're all
down to zero you know whether it's Dave
Chappelle alley we're both down to zero
nobody's doing any [ __ ] time ain't
nobody's doing [ __ ] we're just trying to
get back we're just trying to get over
this thing and but it's so we and how
what we talking about hole even talking
about the fights last night fights out
you know for years we've been trying to
set up Tony and to be Tony and khabib
Tony and Kirby now it's not a fight no
more now it's khabib against Tony and
kabhi begins [ __ ] gay she and Tony
against MacGregor I mean that's all you
see now now I McGregor watch the box see
what some box says i Chavez guy hasn't
[ __ ] thrown a box and pound in 10
years you know this what kills me now we
got good fights with the next card July
could be great whatever the [ __ ]
Island or whatever I mean they these
fights this week I know [ __ ]
Wednesday night's fight it's gonna be
great with Joe Sarah against Anthony and
then Saturday we're Overeem against and
that's Harris my heart goes out to him
and his family he's the one whose
daughter got abducted and killed but
anyway I'm not the UFC guy I just wanted
to speak about how fast life moves and
when everybody's looking at one thing
all of a sudden something happens
unexpectedly you don't control anything
you control yourself and where and what
you want to do and we saw that Saturday
night we're gauging that for me is an
inspirational fight
because he called it and then they gave
may teen days more to study the kid and
I mean I watched uh uh uh you know I
know him I love Tony Ferguson I'm a huge
fan of Tony Ferguson he didn't even let
Tony Ferguson get a [ __ ] submission it
was like Tony Ferguson his jujitsu
wasn't even in the game so was it's
pretty interesting when you look at life
and you that nobody has nothing down you
have dick you don't know nothing you're
as good as you are right now today
tomorrow I don't know dick about yeah
well McGregor is gonna fight this guy
yeah that don't matter
did you see the beat and that gauge he
put on [ __ ] on whatever last night
think about that and then we'll decide
what's gonna happen and then we'll see
if he's gonna fight says a Gomez or
whether the guy with the pantyhose on
the [ __ ] his name is uh obviously
hindsight is 20/20 but like this is
apparently how we don't know how life's
gonna go I feel like the reason I felt
bad for Tony is that was like the second
at least in a room title fight like
change and like to me I don't know
fighters stand to gain anything from
doing like should he have not taken that
fight and though you know I'm gonna wait
for khabib listen it's like life it's
like life you making decisions some
people want to fight some people want to
make the move you know every way again
hindsight is 20/20 you know hindsight is
you know I should have done this I
should have done that I shouldn't have
done the half-hour Netflix I should have
waited for an hour and that book
who would have known you're in the
moment right you know you're a fighter
I'm not here I'm not I'm not cut out to
sit here and wait you know I was never
waited to sit there with my thing and
make believe I'm thinking right I was
always a do it you gotta go do something
every day you gotta do something I don't
know what you're talking about how long
are you talking about I don't know what
you're talking about you do something so
you know this is just just great we've
watched Jay Z come up we've all sat
there and watch gay G come up and
he raised his hand and if you're gonna
raise your hand raise your [ __ ] hand
well he had something interesting that
he said in this interview with Rogen he
said something to the effect of like I
had to lose to fix it like there was
nothing listen you're gonna have to
borrow matey time to become a great
topic and the same thing happens in
fight right now there's a fighter named
Kevin Lee he's a black kid he's lost his
last three fights maybe I don't know I'm
not a fight
but I know by looking at Kevin Lee in
his determination and how hard he works
one day you put everything together it's
all gonna fall together that's why I
keep telling people all the time keep
showing up to the map because no matter
what happens if you keep showing up
you're bound to get better at that thing
doesn't matter when you do come here if
your contractor well they're looking for
experience you start off as a [ __ ]
hot carrier or you picking up papers and
trash and then one day a guide says ta
come here pick a piece of wood help me
cut it measure it boom Bob and then the
next thing the guy's telling you to help
me put it up on the [ __ ] wall and
make sure you know the guy's telling you
hey what are you doing Saturday you want
to do a side job with me and now you've
become you went from being a helper from
being a [ __ ] laborer to being a
carpet to help her and you're laying
wood now now you're cutting measurements
now he calls you at night they'll go hey
tomorrow I'm gonna be there at 9:00 but
have fifteen 4x8 half inch boards cut
four by six so we could do this now you
take more responsibility upon yourself
and you find yourself and then one day
tells you to do something you cut an
angle off you cut you didn't measure it
and you did it wrong guess what it's
gonna cost you money now you have to do
the job over again and even though
you're a good carpenter you got to do a
job over then you're gonna feel like
[ __ ] but you're gonna learn something
from that
so our setbacks always positives if you
do the positive thing from the setback
I don't mind a good setback from time to
time right now how many people getting
set back by this situation this is a
horrible situation
this virus people are getting set back
but you're not gonna worry about I'm not
gonna worry about I can sit here and cry
every episode but I'm losing money by
not going on the road or I could cry
here sit here and tell you how happy I
am they're having cotton to corral the
virus they haven't put my family through
all that and I haven't been in a
hospital bed
so he'd [ __ ] weeks and you know I had
tubes down my throat so in life there's
always something that you have to find
especially on a [ __ ] Monday
mondays are not for everybody
people don't like Mondays for me I come
out of bed Monday with two knives and a
knife in my hand and a razor blade in my
toe I'm ready to stab you somewhere
because that's why I'm on a Monday I
know that Monday sets the pace for the
rest of the [ __ ] week but back to
just engage in life and you know for
months we've been looking at this fight
and look what we seen last night look
what we saw last night you know I bet
there's a bunch of 155 these five is
doing push-ups today you know Dustin
Poirier that's a good fight now that
changes division around meanwhile
McGregor wants to fight some guy wears
pantyhose 20 years ago you know this is
what I'm saying so anyway you poured it
was a great weekend I hope you guys had
a great weekend I hope you guys again
aryen
your lives back to normality little by
little you know this doesn't mean you're
going to a [ __ ] violent show tonight
or a [ __ ] 12 man whatever I'm not
seeing I don't I don't want to see the
apostles okay if anybody comes to you
and says I'm going to a pot as soon as I
count 12 apostles that's when I don't go
please just because the band has been
halfway lifted I care about you still
wash your hands still don't touch your
face and still [ __ ] it and put the mask
on and if you feel that you've been
around somebody or whatever put a mask
on I don't have a mask on today cuz it's
Leigh with social distancing the doors
open and
a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive without further ado listen he's
gonna do the first half on Monday from
79 to when he moved out to Colorado and
then Wednesday we're gonna do we're
gonna finish it off with me going to
prison and he said me standing me doing
stand-up and me doing a bunch of other
[ __ ] so I hope you enjoyed this little
interview of my man George Kyler didn't
scatter off lot of sports and Cliffside
Park he's got a bunch of pictures and
memorabilia up there these cells of mine
anytime Troy Conrad takes a picture of
me or whatever I sent it to him so if
you ever interested he's got a lot of
the stuff he's one of the best framers
in the country so this is my brother
george carlin ski i hope you enjoy it
dad
George my brother what's happening
what up for you people don't know George
Khalid in ski is not from North Bergen
he's an original oh he went to summer
school there in 79 80 and 81 and that
makes him enough Bergen original because
if you're stupid enough to go to North
Bergen high school then you're dumb
enough to hang out with me and I'm
saying good to see your brother what's
up man I'm glad that senior year I
didn't have to go back and he would I
would have got a diploma from Northport
yeah no I would have had to go back my
scene here so I said [ __ ] that I missed
out
I was short like three credits I'll sit
[ __ ] I'm not going to summer school I
went dude I went to graduate and they're
like they stopped me in the hallway like
you know you can't graduate like what
are you talking about it passed you
didn't hand in your 10th grade health
book huh you know they always [ __ ] and
you graduate from st. Cecilia's you even
go to close he's originally from
Cliffside but Cliffside Park Jersey I
want to give it a shout-out because it
has the best seafood restaurant in the
country named Rudy's on the corner the
first ones to serve me since 1979 I used
to walk up there on Monday Night
Football and I'd get a mug of Heineken
and a bowl of calamari for [ __ ] and
nobody said nothing so shout out the
Cliffside Park and Rudy's and they're
open right now man they're open right
now Sunday through the window passing
that [ __ ] through the window but it's
funny our friendship started in 79 I
didn't see you that much till then then
something happened you started dating
the girl from North Bergen and I knew
her boyfriend and I reached out to you
and I said kind of woman yeah you want
to mess with this [ __ ] guy he's out
of his mind
he's my brother I love him the guy
that's why I didn't want I liked it I
got his here I could have told him don't
worry about it the chicks a [ __ ]
dirty animal anyway but then I didn't
see you I didn't see you for years and
one day I'm casing out of joint up an
angle well it was an angle an angle with
clips
Tenafly I'm casing out of where
how something teleplay I hadn't seen you
in for four or five years and I'm
looking at this a lot you know probably
about three years three years probably
because it was like 83 82 around there
and then yet here it was probably March
of 85 I'm minding my business I'm trying
to walk down the street very nonchalant
because of those days there was no
cameras yeah and I see you raking leaves
yeah I go George
Joey and we start talking we connect I
tell you I'm living in a hotel in
Teaneck or what the [ __ ] I think I was
leaving one mr. t at that time still no
no yeah no no not sleeping no I don't
sleep I had just left him I was in a
hotel on a day to day type basis and I
did something I got nailed for saw
possession of stolen jewelry on a
hundred and eighty fifth Street so they
gave me the Fort Lee and Fort Lee didn't
know what to do with me so Fort Lee said
you got a warrant in Bergen County from
1981 for not showing up to court so I
never forget that they took me to the
[ __ ] thing I asked the driver to stop
a chance dragging in because I hadn't
eaten all day they arrested me at two
o'clock
they held me in New York till about 6:00
then at 6:00 they were like just I don't
really know what to do it so forth
Authority brought me over the [ __ ]
bridge they saved me a dollar and a
quarter and you know that that was the
end of that I went to Bergen County Jail
court was like a 10 o'clock at night and
I was late it was late Court and I
remember they made me sit handcuffed to
a guy that had blood coming out of his
[ __ ] head didn't give a [ __ ] at that
time it was ten o'clock court and the
judge said make arrangement to pay the
fine and you got a call somebody to be
released
and it just so happened I had seen you
that day
that day the thing you asked away was
that there was that [ __ ] day cuz I
had your number still in my pocket
written in pencil and I go I don't know
who to call I got one person to call and
I called you and you miraculously picked
up the phone and you said where are you
I told you you go I'll pick you up now
when you came to pick me up I would add
the intention of you were gonna feed me
and then we were gonna get high and I
was gonna go to a hotel I was staying at
on route 4 yeah because I had to stand
at all those route four hotels I would
stand one and get into one argument with
the Hindu and then move to the other
then you came that night you go now
you're not going back to the hotel my
mom said you'd come stay with us and I
was just in shock George I remember
walking in your grandmother your mom
your sister and I'm like what am i doing
in those days your mom had the big
bedroom you had the little bedroom and I
had a little corner on the floor yeah
and it's why you said the first thing I
did was to put my balls in your face I
do not remember those things always the
first couple day yeah we walking out I
usually don't like putting my balls
people's faces when I first meet him the
other day that was really funny we're
talking you go I bailed you out a day
out of jail in the first three weeks
what did I do the first three weeks out
of jail I see well the ball incident was
I was like Tweety bag I need to get a
name for a bad man but you [ __ ] with
dying and I'm still [ __ ] have
nightmares uh then my one of my
ex-roommate's we did a drive-by you like
you live here is he home no you went in
slipped in the window read this I I just
didn't like this dude I didn't like the
way he had spoken to you in front of me
in those days if I didn't like it and
the timing was right I was in arabiya
just for not liking you I was just gonna
rob you and something happened that
there was some beef between you and him
and I'll never forget you were like a
healer's right there he lived close to
the Fairview border on Kennedy Boulevard
across the street yeah yeah yeah the
palms right there up and I remember just
knocking on the door nobody answered I
went around the side I crawled into a
window and I came out with a pair of
speakers and a child alpine stereo and
some type of like hardcore checked like
it was for nothing it was for peanuts
we only got a stereo though what are you
talking about I can't say check like
nothing we went over to this Bank
we knew the teller he didn't need no ID
we - - checked him that was the end of
that nobody's [ __ ] feelings got hurt
well we went to cash that in the city no
we need a pen no a hotel we well we went
the cast I check out 70th and Bergen
line they used to be a Hudson County
United Bank there uh-huh this is how old
my Jimmy runs young Sam that same guy
used to lend you from the vault on
Fridays if you went to him because it
was 1984-85
so if you go to him on a Friday he
worked in a bank ladies and gentlemen
and he's still alive
if he went to if you needed money to buy
a kilo coke on a Friday and you had the
customers already lined up you went to
him on a Friday at 3 o'clock and you
said he could take 25,000 out of the
safe he would give you who's ever money
it was he didn't give a [ __ ] to be
leased I asked I am in fun it could be
GG Mon Tues and he would give you the 25
but you would have to give him back 32
on Monday at 9:00 not Tuesday at 9:00
not Monday night at 9:00 he had to have
the $32,000 in cash and bundles the
whole thing counted because it was going
right to the safe that's how kinky life
was back then when I first started
hanging out with you but I think and
then you
my first Buffalo away I never had a
buffalo I don't like those little
shocking things I had no idea so we went
to the ground round I'm in Inglewood
clearing the wood cliff I'm nine dolly
so we go in there and we [ __ ] drink
you know have a good time as I can all
worry about my tree so the waitress is
the girl I went to kindergarten I mean I
know it all through school I think I was
third grade we were we went out here a
fake romance and then we walk out of
there he's got the bill in his head I'm
like the first guy
my first dining dish and no [ __ ] idea
what it was
no I'm freaking out he's laughing were
laughing I'm like I know how he goes to
uh so like about two weeks later we go
back there I go you got the money
I got come on don't worry about it we do
it again she didn't remember so now all
of a sudden Coco goes and talks to the
manager for like ten minutes he's at the
register with the manager with the bill
in his hand I walk out he comes back
he's [ __ ] blah he's got the bill
again two times within two weeks I
haven't seen her since I have not I used
to kill his ground round every time I
was hungry cuz I didn't have to pay
I had it down to a science I'd walk in
get a bowl I talked to the managers it
was like I knew him I always had enough
to tip so I paid a fine our tip even
though the bill was 28 I'd leave five or
six I always had the money to tip so
they would never suspect me not like I'm
leaving a tip and then I'd wallet only
on the on the table then I'd go to the
thing mingle talk to the manager Tom I
love the suit he had on and that walk
out the reason why I talked to the
manager because if he said to me then
pay at least I could have said hey I got
caught up in the conversation it happens
no is that one of the ones where you can
pay on the way out yeah yeah yeah so you
you leave it on the table you can pay
the wait to see to pay on the way out I
would go up to the Mandalay hey George
how you don't get mugged any lot
everything's all right go pay and I've
just walked past the waitress trusting
everyone trusted when I lived with you
and 85 that run believe it or not do you
know I didn't do any drugs I was just
smoking pot I was 85 I wasn't doing coke
I was just stealing living with you and
just trying to figure out what my next
move of I was trying to get to Colorado
so I got a job working for a masonry guy
and Cliffside Park he only said one word
in English more not more because on a
mortar that's all he ever said Maura
Maura and I worked from for about a
month and a half and then we did a high
stairway to a house next door to like a
house that was kind of loose and I went
back that Friday night and robbed the
house and I didn't show up back to work
Friday because they were gonna blame me
anyway I never heard from them and then
I went to work for this this guy named
Jay a chase construction real [ __ ]
redneck white piece of [ __ ] from
Fairview he would meet me at a diner not
buy me breakfast then he wouldn't pay me
for windshield time he was a real scooch
he would [ __ ] he would [ __ ] you
know bounce checks on me and whatnot and
one weekend he gave me like a check that
was light like the [ __ ] gave me
a check that was like I owe you for 40
hours normally gonna get it for 35 cause
that's the way life is and he goes ah
I'm going down the shore with my wife
we're going on a boat to hang out with
the [ __ ] Rockefellers I'm like really
[ __ ] perfect you just hang you're not
gonna be home all weekend so he wasn't
gone ten minutes I told you I'll be back
in an hour I went up there kicked this
[ __ ] door down
I took whatever cash she had but on the
way out at the bar he had a big bottle
of Dom Perignon all your regular bottles
of Dom Perignon
but the Magnum Magnum I still remember
walking like a Puerto Rican down the
street and [ __ ] Leonia with a bottle
of Dom Perignon in my hand I had the
case so we could sell it but I went back
to the house and it was it was you and I
and late it was late it was like 9:30
9:30 and grandma just come back from
bingo when I moved in with George I also
had the pleasure of introducing his
grandmother and his mother to me who had
now became my pseudo mother and
grandmother there was really weird about
that time we went it was Easter Sunday
and what the only is the Union City and
I got theirs when I left to live with
you and cliff side cliff side there's
only 10 minutes and what Berg but to not
Bergen people it's a world away I was
afraid right there in baseball we would
play you know I think I don't think I
played against you in grammar school
basketball eighth grade well we played
Lincoln we played me we didn't play
McKinley I think we played Robert Walton
and two or three games which we wanted
against all you North Bergen mothers but
when we played baseball or football we
had to go to 64th Street it was a war
zone though we'll give us something like
we got it we got a show and we got a
show in two weeks just dedicated to 64
three but oh my god so I quit that job
with JHS and at the daytime I used to
get the ice to get in those days you
work for your mother
Andiamo yeah we all had somewhere to go
to about five o'clock and in those days
I was just a dream I would walk the
streets and dream of me being on the
boat with [ __ ] me getting my dick
sucked you know on a yacht with Miami
Vice but
I just didn't know I was gonna do it I
just I was so lost George you and I were
young kids we were just lost you had
that Camaro but I was I told the fire
we're no swamp woods we just had no
answers like we had no [ __ ] answers
you know so the only answer I had if I
wasn't gonna sell coke or whatever I
figured out a way when I was staying at
the hotels so going to gas stations that
had a Help Wanted sign and I would apply
for a job I wouldn't apply for 8:00 to
4:00
everybody wants to work 8:00 before
nobody really wants to work four to
twelve but nobody wants to work 12 to 8
so I would start off with the 12:00 to
4:00 for the 4:00 to 12:00
I'd say can I come in here and work for
the twelve perfect they had been looking
for somebody for so long they wouldn't
even check my references no one did from
the news showed up there you called they
don't ask for ID it was I had a guy at a
gas station that our dear friend he had
a list of people he had fired from that
gas station for stealing so I told him
to give me the names of the people he
had fired from that gas station for
stealing and I would apply under those
names into the gas stations and they
would hire me as let's say Steve Lansky
now for people who don't know in New
Jersey and an Oregon are the only states
where they pump gas the guy has to come
out look in the face and go what do you
want
you know like let me get $12.50
irregular and they pump gas when I
figured out what if I got a job at a gas
station pump the gas but never paid for
the gas kept the money in my pocket and
when you got a job they told you for you
not to get robbed you should be safe and
dump every time you get $1,000 so you
were supposed to they would give you an
envelope every hour you were supposed to
put them on
and then dumping in a hole and then when
the manager comes in tonight he pulls
all the cash out I decided that we're
only gonna put $20 bills in those
envelopes and throw him in I'd stock up
I'd wait till I had two or three grand
and then I'd walk off the gas station
site it's not really right minutes 15
minutes before relieve G right before
the next guy I wouldn't even make it
like if I went to work at from 4 to 12
by 8 o'clock I would have $3,000 already
I would hustle I would get even if it
even if it wasn't my Alec I would go to
the full-service Island I was hustling
tips and I was a good employee you know
if you looked at me from the outside
you're like man this guy works little
did they know that you know I was gonna
walk off the light so the first two
times I did it I just like walked off
the lot
jumped over a few yards got to a
different Street and saw a cab driver
and got in and left I just had this luck
that kept happening to me another night
I got thrown out of the one hotel I get
there and my luggage is in the front and
I go buddy bleed to him he goes are you
you supposed to pay by at 12 o'clock I
go bro I told you I was coming back it's
late it's four o'clock so he goes you're
right anyway but he didn't give me the
key back he didn't ask me for my key
back I'm gonna forget this George I got
thirty dollars on my pocket I got enough
to pay for the [ __ ] hotel room and
maybe a bag of chips from the [ __ ]
hallway and I go to a hotel room with
the key that he gave me just to see if I
left anything in there and when I open
the door I hear sucking and [ __ ] in
the room some guys [ __ ] a chick in
the in the shower and I looked down and
the guy's wallet is there with his pants
pocket and like a [ __ ] envelope I
took the wallet and the envelope and I
just told the Hindoo you're right I'll
never come back to this hotel again
he's I get out of [ __ ] you and I ran out
of there
I found the cab I jumped in the cab he
took me over the city
i sat in the city I walked around with
luggage I went the 181st Street I bought
like ten nickel bags and then I went
back to Port Authority took a bus and
they dropped me off of the hotel where
they kill vino you know the hotel where
they kill Vito and The Sopranos and that
hotel that's right there
they just raw did it they just redid
that hotel for that scene but that Hotel
is a dump
it's right there on the other side as
I'm going into Jersey not going into New
York City right so I stayed in there and
then there was the first time when I
opened up I realized I had three or four
grand and I'm like wow this seems like a
great scam to do but I was no smarter
than you
I was the dumbest kid on the block I
didn't go to Teaneck the next day I went
to the gas station two doors down
because I'm route 4 right then there's
like eight gas stations then you would
hit the Grand Union and we would get
that nice Lobster lemon I've had the
cream of the soup right there by the
grand new and then there was another
hotel in there next to the grand
described you I used to live in those
hotels and people were looking for me to
kill me I would stay those hotels they
couldn't [ __ ] find me so one day I
actually just kept getting hope I kept
coming George was the dumbest thing it's
like I would go from your shop where it
is located
to two gas stations down and do the same
scam and I did it to about six of the
eight gas stations and then I had to
think globally you know I'm saying I
can't [ __ ] keep robbing locally so I
started going out to different places
there was a place by like Fort Lee it
was a golf station and by that time me
and you were tight you don't know I'm
robbing gas stations by uh by uh Lisa
machinist there's that that golf right
there now my house yes and I said to you
meet me there I think my shift started
at 4:00 no no yes minou you called me
you were at ben salomo party no
I don't care what happened that Vince
Lombardi elmo's got the reason I called
you from Vince Lombardi was because they
were on to me but Vince Lombardi the
bust had like 20 buses that were leaving
at one shot it was a park-and-ride
Vince Lombardi was probably the last one
I did the last two I did because I got
in a bus and two minutes up I got on the
bus the cops came with their lights on
saw my god dammit they're gonna get me
and I'm on this bus and finally they let
like three buses go and then they
started emptying the buses after that to
see if I was on those buses I was
already on my way to New York I just
called you to give you a good goodbye
like I love you in case they catch me so
but the one I used with you was the gulf
station I called you and I said pick me
up at this place at 7:30 and you were
there all happy Georgie with the [ __ ]
car revving up cousin Ben Ben Ben Ben
Ben and I get and I go step on it he
like step on it what do you mean step I
like I just robbed a gas station you're
like well thanks for giving me [ __ ]
warning you know at least I would
[ __ ] know he gave me warning I was no
hesitation because I didn't know you
didn't know so I used you like on two of
those that you didn't even know you were
just driving around here I am [ __ ]
throwing every what's up the [ __ ]
window and I remember one time he went
to a party we went to like a bar or
something but the most because I didn't
hang out with George I didn't go out at
night if you think I'm like yeah to me
yeah if you thinking all my life I
didn't go out at night I used to go to
the city get a bag of reefer get a
Carvel shake on the way back John
I and I had a job even if even when
you're doing those at night you were
doing something during it that you
always had a job yeah you always said I
always had some type of action going and
then I remember waiting I had sued a guy
me and Cylons had sued some [ __ ] guy
and that may they called me
Cylons got a hold of me I don't know how
the [ __ ] gotta hold meaning cuz cuz I
was allowed enough burger so I got
tiptoe around North Bergen I could take
the Bergen wine boss but I could not go
into North Bergen I couldn't let it go
Michael Julie they still look Michaels
jewelers my godfather
Cubans I had I had maybe five people
looking for me so I I'll know if I am
the son of a cop yeah you want a future
you've even know but at the confluent
looking for me now I'm no cops look
before I was really tight with the chief
of police in North Bergen at the time so
I called them on a weekly just to say
anything pop up because every week I was
getting accused of something and here I
wasn't even living in North Bergen no
boss well now I knew it was like a
running joke between me and him his name
was Joe mr. bussaco so I remember that
one night I found out that I was getting
that check for like eighteen hundred
bucks and I could finally go to Colorado
and you and I you had plans for Saturday
you were doing something Sunday with
Sandra you all right over there you were
doing something with with Sandra on
Sunday and that Friday I robbed a gas
station or that Thursday I did a gas
station and you and I ended up in a club
with my gas Kelis and a red eye the red
pirate and the Eurythmics were that they
weren't performing she was just there
with the guitar player hanging out
that place was crazy that place is crazy
dolls that we got in for free we got
tickets was always one of my mother's
costumes it was something real it was
like a hot Claudia shoulder a stuffed
ah and then we yell and then you had a
something on Saturday so in those days I
was still getting credit cards and I
took Mary Lou and lubes shopping at the
Paramus mall I get whatever you want
gold chains Oh
jackets whatever the [ __ ] you want I'll
I'm in my old your mother money I left
her fur and a draw she was doing
something I think I only got to say
goodbye to Grandma did I didn't see you
85 I didn't see you kept in touch it you
on the phone
yeah then when did we reconnect in
Colorado before you move to Colorado to
Colorado to me and Hassman
no we would talk and I was working now
you know my mom's place I didn't make a
lot of money I was like that just
learning how to frame pictures and [ __ ]
so uh you know to make more money I got
a real job I learned trade a little more
so I worked this job I got like my first
paid vacation you know so I he's what
I'm gonna do in July I go visit you you
weren't Snowmass I spend a few days
there then I was gonna go to Scottsdale
Arizona visit this girl Karen that I
went to school with that moved out be
able to family we had been you know I
remember back then no cell phones no
computer
you called somebody on a Thursday night
at 10 o'clock the toy and of course you
you know 15 bucks to talk on the phone
to someone long distance plan this big
trip I'm gonna go there - great vacation
so we head out to uh visit you and
snowman's
and you got this great scam because
you're house-sitting you took all the
food of Brenda's Jimmy Burkle purple so
uh God also when we're driving there's
like branches all over the place
beautiful I think you would call pick me
up right
is that his name call call
out of North Carolina oh god I remember
see these like cows on the sideline man
dogs big dogs roundup going on so your
house in it you've got a little like
apartment sort of connected up to some
huge huge house now Snowmass is like
we're asking is it's you know big money
big big money well you're in the main
house because the people never come this
right you got to run okay yeah I'm
living like a doctor in the house dr.
Cathy came you know we're eating great
within you you've got you know
everything is set up the way you want
yeah you're running that town and so I
spent a couple days and that's like the
beginning it again because that one
night I remember you roll this joint
we had Arkansas homegrown it was cryovac
now we're talking 85 rate 85 85 summer
cryovac homegrown it was like sense it
was tremendous so you took that weed
and you cooked a half gram of a blow and
then this was the beginning of like you
know
freebase bazoom full right well they
made a Paducah called it a [ __ ] basura
palma mezuzahs enjoy and that night I
looked outside my bedroom had to guess
from them had a door that was like on a
mountainside and I just looked in the
sky was purple and blue and I've never
seen anything like you know the house is
gorgeous today that's it packed it up I
went to Arizona the girl I've been
talking to for a year that week she
started going out with the linebacker on
Arizona State
so that's who picked me up from the
airport so that trip was [ __ ] dead
and I think I shot back for a couple of
days I went to LA went by you and that's
how we connected again you know it's
funny like doc the people don't know the
Zuka like in the early eighties it was
freebase and everybody who you know no
you couldn't just north the coat nah you
can't just [ __ ] snort it now I gotta
[ __ ] cook it and put it to a silk
scarf and then look for it to dry what a
[ __ ] process what only white people
could do something like that
that white people do add [ __ ]
[ __ ] the [ __ ] so then then they
started a different thing what a time I
got to North Bergen in 84 when I made my
mistake and came back from work for a
year
Our Mutual Friend Rago got me into
bazookas and bazookas well you got a
coffee cup you put three fingers of
water in it you put three tenths of a
gram of baking soda and you put a gram
of coke in it and then you put in the
microwave close the door set it at
twenty four seconds and when you heard
Bing that's it you took it out a little
boat little Boulder would be in the
thing you took it out you put it on like
a piece of paper and then you crushed it
and you rolled it into a [ __ ] joint
or you dip it into a Marlboro red and
you watch your eyeball pop out and it
started with 110 I remember then we melt
so now you go back to now you stay with
me in Aspen for about a week yeah and
you go back to New Jersey what happened
is in New Jersey well let's see I think
I think I learned how to cook coke
because it was 85 still it was 80
everybody's getting high so but uh guess
what I know how to cookie so I'm the
most popular guy around because I don't
have to spend a dime they just invite me
over and I'm like the official cooker so
I'm working for my mom I'm working at
this other place and
you know in the weekends Jesus Christ
moon just closed I was booming
everybody was selling drugs everybody
was getting high
yeah everybody was everybody everybody
was so uh you know we got into that so
now in the meantime I had taken the
police test my dad my dad was a cop an
honest cop a good cop good guy and I
took the test and I passed everything
and all of a sudden is coming down
anywhere you know take psych test and
I'm in I just couldn't be a cup I just
you know it just was it wasn't in my DNA
my dad was but uh you know so did you
read the psych arrest of all was that
did you take the tight the psych test no
psych test now you got good back then I
mean I'm [ __ ] nuts but I didn't want
to be a comedy I didn't want I don't
know what I wanted to be I don't know
like a firefighter or they want to be a
quarterback I don't know who the [ __ ]
knows but uh so you had moved to bowl
and you're like you know what why don't
you just come out here you and Kathy
moved from from Snowmass whatever
happened over there so I'm like you know
what [ __ ] I think I was living in
Hoboken for that year when I came back I
missed the whole boat I was living it up
in a sublet tremendous was great time a
lot of fun but I was trying to go so uh
I moved to Boulder with you I moved
there you know it was right after the
Giants won the Super Ball after they
beat the mighty Broncos I got off that
plane with a giant shirt and they broke
my balls in the second I got me you got
there like oh maybe
March or February of 87 Easter what was
your impression of me at that time how
did I appear to you in 87 like I
remember you fell asleep at the airport
cuz J launches an X's or bound you had
to bring me a Cuban sandwich you told me
grab some sons drink some stuff with you
so whatever money I had and I'll be dead
it does two dollars off I went out there
I spent like four on blow so I took USN
remember you were saying with this so to
go to go to Denver from Newark you had
to stop and pitch for the Pittsburgh
connection
you also got I remember airports back
then had lockers like a school locker
he put a quarter in you turn the thing
he took the key so I'm all paranoid I'm
high you know I got like 12 layover and
nine in Pittsburgh
and I start hitting the package I don't
know where I was but it made the first
flight so now I gotta call you so now
before I left he said bring me a Cuban
sandwich so I'm thinking hey it's not
before the seven three on the way to the
airport before I tell him you know what
don't cook it just give me the Cuban
sandwich without pressing I put that in
my suitcase my carry-on bag so I'm stuck
in Pittsburgh I miss like three flights
in Pittsburgh I was there about 20 hours
it was two days I stepped on the airport
to pick you up no [ __ ] George no two
days and now I get on the plane to
frigging wasn't there wasn't cellphones
do you could say [ __ ] me up a terminal
we have an answering machine I've made
nothing
so uh all of a sudden I'm about an hour
from mine from Denver and I smell this
[ __ ] foul smell I'm like what how
because I was passed out on the plane
it's the friggin she
that I've had in my bag for like 20
hours so they didn't put it in a press
but it already changed form just by the
molecules in the air and so this thing
stinks everybody the plane is like what
the cut so I get off the plane you pick
me up you're laughing you light a joint
I go listen I got this sandwich I go by
the auto so wish me I wouldn't need you
like ripped it out of my hands like it's
not cooked yet
you [ __ ] ate that sandwich in the
parking lot I was looking at all the way
that's [ __ ] nasty food that lasted
vegetarian [ __ ] I would have him [ __ ]
sandwich
I got nightmares about that Cuban
sandwich still a bit attacking me so
that was it so I went so he drives me to
his frigging you're at new place you
know he's got like two roommates I think
it was two or three two I was a couple
in one room the truck it shall be
brought to chubby red and then a cat and
uh just had kids Coco I have dog
Hercules it was lavador uh he was he uh
he was a shepherd mix I mean the
greatest dog areas blend of Hercules
Norman and his kids cocoa I didn't even
know he jumped but he's juggling three
kids he's gone touchy Kings all of a
sudden he goes watch this he throws one
kitten
Hercules like this huh catch you soon is
the kid
I don't like he just killed a kitten not
Hercules gonna use a deep saw his mouth
was like Jerry Rice's hands you know I
was saying he just soft caught the
kitten put it down he was ready for
another he's like come on dad do it so I
think I stayed there like two days a
song because you were just moving out we
had a spare bedroom one of the guys
thought he was like a [ __ ]
entrepreneur that's when the word
intrapreneur came out
and he's I don't want a day job I want
to get intrapreneur so he would wake up
every morning and go to [ __ ] talk to
those people
Toastmasters and he come back way
because I was leaving to go to work he'd
be coming back and I was selling cars at
a place called Hollister dodge Hollis
yes the Plymouth so before George comes
out I asked them can George get a job as
a lot man they go does he have a license
I said yes so we get him a job as a lot
man we're there at that south boulder
apartment maybe two weeks right we got a
50 a week to bedroom fifty a month a
month for the [ __ ] the the job we
stayed at that house for maybe two weeks
at the other half of those people it
wasn't long it wasn't long I had a
little affair with the redheaded chick
yeah big red tits there was one couple
there was a couple the chick was hot
with a boyfriend a were like they didn't
leave each other ones the garage one
night she slipped out his room towards
the garage and then there was a chubby
red chick that I love to death I used to
bike or but when she got kicked we get
coked that she would want to suck dick
and her boyfriend passed outside bring
her over to my room and we'd swap spit
and that's a family own the printing
shop she was rich because they owned a
printing shop I still remember that but
but that was a wild apartment we had I
remember the first party we had there
I ate a bunch of coatings but I just I
just woke up really sick like I realized
that day I couldn't take coatings of
pills of that major
I never took another [ __ ] codeine
girl again but that was not that was a
weird
we lived with four people you stayed in
the one guy's bedroom while he was gone
you know I'm working at this car place I
gotta say I'm 25 years old I don't have
any direction George comes out he's got
no [ __ ] directions y'all and we had
between us was love we had nothing else
and all sudden we start booming a little
bit George at the West End Cafe the
western tavern you started working with
the lessons
yeah well Street as a dishwasher or
something but full-time you worked on a
lot and got around town because you
would steal cause from a lot and
politeness plates are all the colors you
would follow in charge of all these are
my job I was a charger struggling the
cars around the spot to spot and gassing
them all up and again I'm from Jersey
Joey Joey was telling you about
you know pumping gas Colorado you got a
pump your own gas well for the first
month of that job I didn't because I
never did so they get a bill they pull
me in after the first month of work in
there sage what what the hell is going
on I know what he talking about it go
there you know our monthly gas budget
you know you your own 25 percent over
what we normally pay I'm like that's odd
they like you do know you're supposed to
pump your own gas right am I know so
they [ __ ] already I'm on the raid off
and it would have fired me right there
was you they love to are you born in a
full-service yeah that'll serve it and
then I taught you that what you do is
when people give you a receipt for gas
like they'll go Lisa at Jorge's here to
drive a car the test drive a car I would
go Lee here's a ten dollar gas to see
you ain't putting that down in the
[ __ ] car you're gonna save that
you're gonna drive that car Lonnie
you're gonna go to the back and have
service give you another gas lip
and then now you save up on gas lips so
George was saying we were saving up on
gas lips that was born into our car guy
you could say put fifteen but give me a
receipt 20 25 yeah and they would do it
so it was a complete different world
we'll make him money on the lot then
George figured out you can rent cars to
be from the line and [ __ ] use the
dealer plates no this is you can't I had
to work I had to work one time on New
Year's Eve actor actor at the West West
Side town and uh it was far South Pole
so it was like four five miles and it
was snowing so I went into the office
I'm like listen can I borrow a car
tonight
I said gotta work and you know I'm not
drinking or anything and that the
manager that was my man's name your
girl's name I don't know the girl's name
a member we had Roberto like like a guy
named Wayne or status Darryl was the
crazy Vietnam vet yeah Oh Dow Jones
that'll jog same way they give me like
an old Mazda pickup truck up to you take
for the day they give me the plate
they'll like just bring this back when
you come back so what happened was I'm
like well if I stay late at work and
everybody leaves I got all I can take
whatever car I want home and then just
get it back and park it in the back and
a lot so what happened was that the
owner the manager said to me after I
took a call home he called me up look
listen I'm gonna pick you up because I
want you to do something with me now I'm
like [ __ ] so I had to take the truck
that I brought home and hide it around
the corner
then this guy drove me to work so now I
got a truck out at the house
you know they got 48 got a 200 cause
they're what's the odds of them trying
to sell that [ __ ] blue truck
brand-new
em truck well guess what somebody wanted
to buy that brand-new truck and they
couldn't find it
that happened oh uh oh my god but we had
and then what happened was you worked at
the dodge store I worked at the Chrysler
store the Dodge store the owners are in
there watching you so it was kind of
weird but even then the Chrysler store
we were running amuck there was four
salesmen and all manager and my life I
left Subaru for peace of mind I was at
Subaru and I was at Douglas Toyota and I
had it been and all these car dealers
where it's stressful it's like you're
not you're not stopping you're gonna
make money at the end of the month
you're gonna make eight or nine grand in
1988 that was a lot of money
87 yeah that was a lot of money but
you're not gonna but at these small
dealerships you made three grand and you
did what you wanted
you got a demo you won Emmys you went to
the demo and then we just went on a tab
like George and I it started like on in
July and we just we had not the
dealership intact but we had the whole
community intact there was a mall across
the street of the Mesa mall and table
minutes they had a thing called things
remembered a store called Things
Remembered and anything I needed money I
would walk in and ask the girl world
where the pens at the cross the cross
pens and she would open the thing for me
and walk away
and I would steal ten cross pens walk
him across the street and sell the cross
pens to the salesman people were giving
me orders I would go from dealership to
dealership and people go hey what
happened to that silver cross grow
cross pen so now I would have you on a
list so next time I went in there I
would have to steal a gross friend it
was just a horrid horrid existence the
manager at the Chrysler store sold
cocaine okay listen to me
judge on Roberto what was his name Joe
Roberto was the guy in Christ the store
the guy at the dodge store the guy at
the crisis door was name was already
Pressler great guy Artie great guy great
salesman big time Jew out of the Bronx
six foot six big but he could [ __ ]
itself he took me under his wing and I
became his protege and he taught me how
to [ __ ] sell a car correct we deposit
work it I mean he was just a good guy
but he sold coke so I went in the
morning and I would go on in let's cut a
deal let me get a gram of coke on the
arm he'd go already
and we would be snorting coke in there
at 11:00 in the morning customers have
come on the lot not me
and there was you guys you will you you
were partly different but at the same
time I had the keys to the soda machine
keys to the soda machine we had we had
the newspaper to bowl the camera we had
about three of those machines Jimmy so
we would open it up get that challenge
ten bucks a day in quarters there and
then when you would unload the soda
machine
I would although I had the keys to the
soda machine and I called my ATM machine
because the guy would leave the dollar
bills in there he would take the change
out and put it into dollar bills I don't
know why till this day so I would have
to get there early to eat breakfast I
would have to open up my ATM machine
take some dollars out and we would eat
breakfast at jack-in-the-box up to
qualia they had something about 10 10
pounds of quarters
in that little what's that little thing
the armrests have no [ __ ] family we
used to have a guy that used to pick up
George that got out of jail for robbing
banks him all this he was robbing
bassinet too and he used to pick up
George him his girlfriend would McGeorge
up everyday and George would still be
[ __ ] late yeah Georgia this little be
late like George they're outside waiting
on you she was very nice
nobody ever thought of [ __ ] Allah she
was very nice what the [ __ ] are named
shorts
yes Andy very sweet woman and she took
care of the bank robber he had just
gotten out of jail yeah he was really
selling cars was it cancer care this
place was a cast of characters they
don't Jones it was ready at any moment
to just pull out an assault weapon Dale
Jones was still living in Vietnam and
burger Hill and he would come in Hamburg
a hill he would come into a room and go
like this make his hand slam back and
forth that meant he was selling the car
so he would come to get his hands and
knees and slam his hands back and forth
and then they'd go watch me sell a car
baby and he would do coke and then and
then whatever his name was the manager
the good good heart guy Artie couldn't
take us couldn't take this [ __ ] spill
in Coke no more so he gave the coke
operation to a guy who robbed and robbed
and Oh Rock robbed and oh I made it my
personal mission
did you tell what you rob what if he was
a great guy he was a a blue he was a
bass player but he was an old cat that
got married so now he had kids because
there's more of the story
you got the toy to certain people God
puts certain people in your life for a
reason you think Jesus just popped up
and did parts to this is pilot life
like happens so my goal with one thing I
could say about what was his name again
the salesmen are you but are you a rock
robbed and oh yeah
one thing I could say about rap Dan
though is he could sell a [ __ ] Jarrah
hamish to Isis he could sell you he was
brilliant when he came into work and
once he did a blast of coke you were bi
and he'd be sweating and [ __ ] shaking
his head the whole thing so I had a
connection with him he liked he didn't
like cross pens
he liked red the other ones the ones
with the arrow aha
all right he liked those red ones he
said there were his lucky pens there's
good luck yeah your luck pants so I
would he became like a three month for
three months I made him I watch it I
think he even ended up going to an
insane asylum because he would cop a
Haunter coke but he wasn't allowed to
bring it home because of his wife and
kids so he would stash it in the seat
above the shelf above the ceiling so I
would get there at 6:00 in the morning
the guy from service ago Joey what are
you doing you sore leg I gotta meet a
customer there's no customer I would go
in the ceiling take Rob's coke out take
coke out of every package and put like
aspirin powder and all the packages and
sell it back and put it back in the
single like nothing happened and then I
let him come to work I let him do a
couple lines of coke I let him grab a
customer I wouldn't are I didn't care if
the customer was gonna buy and let Rob
have him because that was gonna turn
into an 8-hour thing because in the
process of Rob selling the car I was
gonna steal his patent his lucky red for
he is coked up he has a car he has a guy
waiting to [ __ ] sell my car and he
would go up to already Pressly's desk
with the worksheet
and the pen and fill out the stuff and
then in his cocaine mine he would leave
the pen on the counter go back into the
office and that's when I would come and
take the pen okay
and now he would come out and go where's
my lucky red pen and arty would go I
don't know he talking about nobody would
see it I would hide him in the back now
for an hour this kid would not sell that
car until he had a lucky red pen he
would look under cars in the interior
you look in the demos the poor customers
would be waiting and he tell him the
customers ago what are we doing here and
he goes I can't say in the car without
my lucky red pen smile I'd wait all the
way to the end he was gonna get far like
you know the people gonna lose and then
I go rob I got an extra one in the car
for you for 20 bucks it'll give it to me
right now he'd give me like ten bucks
whatever it was for the pen but I just
kept reselling them pens same every time
he had a customer do you recently and I
just stole from him and I would just put
it in a fake box and take it out of the
box in front of him he never knew like I
wouldn't have I wouldn't even be sealed
I would just put the pen inside the slot
and give him the box and he would just
crash it I told this story years ago and
he contacted me on Facebook and I along
with you I went to therapy for years I
yeah my favorite part about all these
stories is you guys open it up with you
know we're pretty good employees oh no
no there was a there was a and then he
joins work in partnership with this kid
that was half [ __ ] Chris Miller was
the same but there was a young kid there
was a glasses yeah good that works on my
side but he had a hot girlfriend oh oh
that little [ __ ] yeah they had a guy
girlfriend and just before I left he
started he became a coke dealer
she worked yeah and we set him up we set
him up completely like I did a [ __ ]
something out of a movie like I sold the
car but the car had to get picked up in
Tucson Arizona yeah yeah yeah I had to
go get the car so he had to leave the
keys to his house and the thing so I
went into his house smoothly took the
coke closed the door like nothing
happened he came back two days later
that was like the beginning of the end
at Chrysler that was it like that was
that caused too much pain people were
crying I had that there was another kid
that was a nice white kid that was from
now is Scott Miller no there was Scott
Miller but there was another very nice
white guy I was losing his hair really
that's the glass he doesn't do drugs he
was from the Dakotas he was the one dude
that thought that was from his brother
was a pilot right from the Dakotas and
we used to fight I couldn't get weed in
the Dakotas so he would send these
Indians down to me on Saturday to buy
weed from Dakotas so they I couldn't
make much profit aful I'll off the price
why because I would only get to bleed
for like eight and I could only get a
thousand out of them I don't know I'm
just making up numbers and I wasn't
making a big profit margin yeah so the
only way I can make a big profit margin
alamos if I took out half the weed and
took a spray bottle and I would spray
the weed until it was a little bit
before drenched I would put it all back
and I would keep announced seal it and
when they would come they'd wait and
they go it's twelve ounces by the time
they got back to not too cold it was
nine ounces because the water weight
would drop and I would take an ounce I
mean just what was going on at this time
was just George's on his own tear I was
out
oh [ __ ]
I forgot all about that story when I was
[ __ ] selling weed for the Indian stuff
[ __ ] they would come down like a
pound of weed and I would take two
ounces out and get a mist fine mist
bottle and I would break it into two
bags so it would be like eight ounces
and two bags to make sixteen ounces and
I would spray them with a water the buds
and I would get it to it was perfect
like if they got there late I don't have
to respray it because I was [ __ ] the
hydrate or whatever the [ __ ] there you
go out of respect from the Indians there
he go so you know what I'm lying don't
worry about it
all fine so uh it was just really weird
how I did that [ __ ] you know George
lived with me obviously before the
kidnapping we're gonna go into that an
episode too but this was just I wanted
you guys see where my head was at briar
you know I was 25 years old I had no
control I was I didn't give a [ __ ] I
mean when I started hanging out with
George I was basically 22 when his
family took me and his family took me in
guys just sight unseen like he bailed me
out of bergen county jail took me to the
hotel room I took the duffel bag I had I
had a duffel bag in those days and I
went to his house and they treated me
like family like I had known them for 20
years I mean how many people does that
happen to and they were Spanish and I
had been away from Spanish people for
years so for me just to get back on that
circle with them it was so special like
they brought me back to reality I was
cleaning off coke had gotten clean that
uh January of 85 and I stayed with
George till July of 85
yes I worked and I Ronald and I did
everything but I was sober I had a
purpose
I had a Donna shoulder scam where I'd
fall on my shoulder and I did some
damage and that friend of mine talked me
into suing him and I sue them so and
they gave me partial payment and another
partial payment like I told you guys
I've never been a type of guy that you
have to look at you never have to tell
me when to leave I know when it's time
to leave always have that gift that you
know when it's time to exit that you
don't get exited and it was just time to
leave but I love George I had a place in
his family I could have stayed there
forever I had I really feel bad and
guilty at times because I probably had
four or three sets of people ever really
really looking to get ahold of me then
and do some nasty [ __ ] to me and I in a
way put them in danger but the people
that were looking for me
didn't know how to maneuver their way
out of North Bergen they will you know
it's like when people leave them or the
mafia money the mafia doesn't go to
[ __ ] with Ginny the gay they just play
the odds they know that you're gonna
come back for some and they'll get you
when you come back I stayed clear in
North Bergen Heights didn't step foot in
North Bergen not even to let them know I
was in the area they all thought I was
in [ __ ] southern New Jersey I would I
would write letters and take rides out
to [ __ ] southern New Jersey and write
letters to my friends so they thought I
was staying Amish or meanwhile I was in
their [ __ ] backyard so always
remember if you're gonna hide from
somebody I'd write back in their
backyard they won't even know you're
there
I'm happy you [ __ ] listen today
I told you I'm putting my friends on
that could tell you every [ __ ] story
I'm not here to verify stories I just
want you guys to know what I was exposed
and how lucky I am
how many people would open up their
homes to a 22 year old [ __ ] loser
who's just getting out of bergen county
jail comedy was not even on my radar
back then if you notice there was no
talk of us even discussing comedy on our
radar it was straight up [ __ ] being a
savage so I hope you got something out
of Monday more than podcast what's up
Lee but you've mentioned before how when
you were younger
you because of the Godfather you wanted
a brother and then all these people did
all this stuff for you and you're very
open with your house I'm not saying
you're not but has any part of you ever
thought about doing something like
people do feel like if mercy and a
friend who needed to come over like have
you thought about that when mercy before
mercy was born if you remember that was
our office yeah I was on to bed bull I
got the bedroom because I thought up my
time that my niece is going to come to
college out here ah so I got that
bedroom for a nice it just so happened I
knocked my [ __ ] wife up okay and it
became a bedroom for my daughter but in
reality yes I always think that someday
before I die my daughter's gonna come
home with a friend or somebody who's not
a good position you know and a couple
weeks I'm gonna have a different Julio
Rodriguez on here who we spoke about
Julio was my friend in the fifth grade I
lived with Julio's family pretty much in
the fifth grade even though I had a
mother and a dad and I had a house
because my house was haunted
so I just would go to the house at night
and stay there and nobody's got a word
you know when I lived when the Rani's
took me in you know when the Bender's
took me in they took me and there was no
paperwork to file there was a kid who
needed a place and they opened down home
to me when that my mother's wake the
Aviles came up to me and asked me do you
want to live with us you know I've just
always been that lucky that God took
away my family but replaced it with a
family you know July 1st this year I'm
all on my 20th anniversary with my wife
Wow and yeah they her and I were just
laughing about the last 10 years like
what's happened the last 10 years a kid
a podcast a CD touring you know this is
really the first time we've had a chance
to talk in the last 10 years you know
since we got married on the mine ain't
gonna 10th or something so the second 10
years is a lot different than the first
yes it is and it's just really
interesting about how we're stronger now
like this happened at a time when a
family would get weak to 20-year mark
it's making me and my wife stronger than
we've ever been and it's creeping over
into my daughter my daughter is starting
to see this so it's just like I told you
people in the beginning of this horrible
horrible horrible pandemic I knew was
gonna be bad but I don't know is gonna
be this bad and I didn't know that
people gonna be dying in Florida and you
aren't gonna be allowed to go say
goodbye to your loved ones and and all
this [ __ ] but I also called something
from the beginning of this podcast and
from the beginning of this pandemic that
there was gonna be a silver lining to it
yeah you probably gonna lose your
[ __ ] job but because of that you and
your girlfriend are becoming um become
tidally you and your brother becoming
become tighter or you and your mother
being a compiler or because of the
pandemic you realize that you learn how
to draw and you know how to decide on
drawing instead of going back to your
[ __ ] office job there's gonna be
silver linings for everybody in all this
and I hope you all get that from this I
know you're all
living in in the in time right now you
know I going Joey how can you say this
I haven't gotten a rent check in three
weeks I haven't gotten my stimulus check
I haven't gotten this but you got your
[ __ ] out and you got your mind and
you got your soul and you got your
[ __ ] heart so that's a lot more and a
lot of other [ __ ] people got so
before you start worrying about what you
don't have
let's worry about what you do have and
what you could do with it and that's it
and that's that
it's a [ __ ] Monday on the [ __ ]
church [ __ ] and I hope you
enjoyed it I hope you got some laughs
out of it like I say this podcast is
stories sometimes it turns into
something serious in the next couple of
weeks there might be a couple tears shed
because we're gonna dig into some
[ __ ] topics from my youth but
whatever it is we're always here for you
we know you're going through a good time
I also wanna thank you [ __ ] for
supporting the podcast we got more dates
I don't know when I'm going on the road
again who gives a [ __ ] everybody's
breathing [ __ ] dark smoke are you
coming to Michigan that's three months
from now the [ __ ] knows by that time the
jobs might bomb them with the Kawasaki
disease we might bomb them we don't know
what's going on every day there's a new
story and you bother me were you
supposed to come to our Paso this
weekend yeah I'm gonna fly in all the
[ __ ] huff and puff the [ __ ] comes
to you and our password we push that to
the january/february like I told you get
your money back don't worry button done
God knows when this is coming back you
[ __ ] over there sitting there
with your 400 hours Rage Against the
Machine tickets put some salt and pepper
on them can you taste them no you look
good at them send those things back
[ __ ]
anyway it's Monday wash your [ __ ] this
for you to start the week off on the
right leg I hope you enjoyed Georgie
coward is key part 2 is Wednesday when
we go through the kidnapping and how it
affected him and how it affected me and
the whole thing I love you guys have a
great day stay black kick this
[ __ ] mule Lee
[Music]